Dmitri only came into the Election
Commission office to quit his job he
wanted to return the election material
he'd plans to distribute election staff
here in Donetsk say they're working
under constant threat a violent incident
on monday was the final straw for Dmitri
the group of armed men with automatic
weapons detained three members of the
Election Commission took them outside
and threatened them the front of
children people were threatened with
death we can't work they don't provide
us with security we fear for our lives
Maria the problem of intimidation at
election offices in Donetsk is
widespread flooding McCloskey is also
working to set up next Sunday's vote
earlier this month marked men raided his
office they took computers with crucial
personal data they returned a few days
ago cuz always true not they said they
were sent here to warn you that you
either stopped working voluntarily or we
can't be responsible for your lives as a
normal human being i have a
self-preservation instinct and i'm
concerned about saving my life julia
potato what happens we did but at the
same time I realized that my country
needs me at this moment in a more
positive suya medium the switch it
privet denis the self-styled on its
people's republic has openly vowed to
disrupt the election it's claimed
autonomy in the region since holding its
own referendum and it refuses to
recognize the current government in Kiev
or its successor a territory of Daniel
script in the territory of the Donetsk
People's Republic there can't be
presidential elections it's not right
it's a logical and will destabilize the
situation in the region we will have a
tough reaction to any attempt to have
presidential elections in our region on
May twenty-fifth rashmi giving the
hospital my auntie but mr. clasky has a
firm response to this thinly veiled
threat see a routine like a superb
restala this person who calls himself
chairman of
central election commission is not
referring to any material law even their
own law even the law of the country they
made up they don't have a constitution
they don't have a state all their
actions are totally illegitimate
absolute law Nezzer cooney election
officials say they believe local people
in donetsk do want to vote but in the
separatists stronghold of slovyansk we
found little enthusiasm for an election
lemme 9 for me they have no meaning I
don't plan to vote I don't know what to
say the illegitimate government wants
some elections gorget gegita we booked
it people here may not even be able to
get to polling stations with many roads
cut off by fighting or improvised
blockades it will be difficult to hold
an election a few hundred kilometers
away in the eastern city of Kharkov the
mood is more positive the pro-russian
movement is active here too but there's
a sense of normality on the streets
people seem to want a central government
in Kiev even if they're concerned about
the future Dodger a broken nose my ears
to be I think the elections should take
place so that a stable government is
established because in the light of
current events when Regents want to
split in all that I think we still need
a stable government the less developers
like organizes at the office of the
front-runner in the presidential race
Petro poroshenko say their candidate can
find a solution to the crisis yeah
Ferguson and he is the only candidate
who can unite the country bring together
east and west all the regions together
in the current situation mr. Ward a
cushy support of jacuzzi for Lisa plots
but here to local election officials
fear the vote could be disrupted workers
at this polling station are organizing
battery-powered lights after warnings
separatists may sabotage the power
supply during a vote count the vote is
likely to go ahead in most places too
bite the crisis but whether the winner
can unite people in the east of the
country's remains to be seen